votre vidéo vous est présenté par
victoria tirer talents.com vous avez
plus de 5000 follower sur vos réseaux
sociaux
venez nous rejoindre et devenez
influenceurs grâce à victoria tirer
talents.com
benjamin castaldi et là vous avez fait
vous moi j'ai fait un week-end
infirmerie mois avait trois enfants sont
encadrés que la grippe était c'était
quoi ces enfants avec la grippe
ouais sur quatre abandons sur 4 ha ouais
mais ils sont acquis et ses enfants il y
en a un peu à moi elle a peur parce que
je crois que pour recueillir des enfants
c'est tout à votre honneur elle met un
peu compliqué week-end à la lâcheté des
thermomètres on a acheté plein de
médicaments
c'était sympa mais c'est balo contenant
les bulletins qui était malade pourquoi
t'as pas écarter les autres
ouais mais bon la vie oui sans dire
pourquoi tu l'as pas abandonné matthieu
delormeau
tout d'abord on a besoin d'un alibi à
quelle heure se s'est passé capucine à
l'avs ça s'est passé à 15h30
15h03 15h30 année tant couscous et ouais
eh oui matthieu delormeau où étiez vous
à 15h30 alors moi j'ai très facile à
vérifier ce que voulait pas en parler
mais tant pis chahine avait rendez-vous
et je l'étais fort à
j'étais je vais récupérer nos badges
j'étais à nrj 12 pour signer mon nouveau
contrat
alors on vous étiez bien dire jalousie
va s'emparer de mes petits camarades
d'un départ j'étais pas dans ces chaînes
là mais forcément dans une autre qui
veut également sa part de gâteau et ça
peut ça peut s'entendre du lys était à
haïti ce jeudi m6 m6 absolument je sais
qui cherche des gens pour nettoyer
l'accueil contentez vous de donner votre
avis moi tout après ma soeur m'a appelé
pour me dire qu'elle venait ce soir
dormir chez moi pendant deux trois jours
pour un projet professionnel avait
besoin de mon ordinateur tournant la
page ben helli j'allais lui passer le
mien et du coup je me suis dit mon
ordinateur et blindés de photos plus ou
moins compromettantes et donc j'ai passé
l'après-midi à nettoyer mon disque dur
pour pas qu'elle tombe sur des choses
qui auraient un boucher donc j'ai passé
toute l'après midi à faire ça vous avez
des gays vous avez vous avez nettoyer
votre disque dur
est-ce que vous avez également déployer
votre disque au bout camille combal
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
la zac terme annoncés à bas mi combat
l'autre qu'on est là alors tu à [ __ ]
ouais demi ouais j'suis et lui demande
il ya sherlock holmes ce qu'aimer rien
récupéré sur une enquête à bois derrière
normalement les services le blues où il
est vendu avec une pipe mois mais on
sait déjà qui a déjà travaillé sur tf1
benjamin benjamin et qui d'autre mathieu
connais pas les autres je sais pas les
autres - coup j'ai fait des grandes
émissions là bas quand même teneur sur
tf1
ouais c'est youzhny s'est fait deux
heures de deux ans nous sommes
maintenant 10h le mag attend merci marie
j'ai fait donc deux vip avec le petit
bateau que des émissions qui ont
cartonné quoi je suis merci non monsieur
je vous aime beaucoup mais j'avais
oublié
je suis désolé pourtant pour moi autant
pour moi je donne juste un chiffre
langues de vip 30 individus et merci la
chouette c'est vrai à la fin le jour
ouvré samoa n'ont pas vous le thé des
nouveautés f1 d'aujourd'hui qui est la
taupe mon premier choix mathieu mathieu
delormeau et la taupe est ce que mathieu
de l'angola tôt pour vous c'est qu'il a
tombèrent pour moi c'est mathieu parce
qu'il avait des gestes et simin et un
peu aussi une empathie n'est pas du tout
efféminé
non mais il avait des petits gestes
alors ils avaient dit qu'il y ait été
miné alors on va revoir et regarder
[Musique]
c'est quoi
et c'est parti pour ce coup sa volonté
qu'un peu en revanche vraiment capus tu
bouges de couteau j'étais un petit peu
loupé mais la prochaine fois je ferai
alors je t'aurais pleine face j'étais
bellaïd la taupe gedia ne s'est pas
didier matthieu 10 très bien
[Applaudissements]